j'accueille patrick 10
[Musique]
on commence à ouvrir messieurs et la
porte s'ouvre pour laisser sortir pas
fait 10 définitivement reconnu innocent
après 15 en prison autour de lui ses
presque l'émeute
tout le monde veut voir patrick guille
l'approché le toucher et entendre ses
premiers mots d'homme libre extrêmement
pas tant la décision qui doit être
rendue mais tous ceux qui sont bien sûr
pas tous des enfants se passe c'est trop
compliqué cette fois
va falloir du temps pour analyser la
situation et les premiers on vit
aujourd'hui
quand je disais tout à l'heure retrouver
ma famille retrouver mes amis et puis
souffler parce que je suis fonctionnaire
je lui ai dit et j'ai envie de me
reposer
des grilles de ces théories du ciel on
n'en sort pas indemne
ne pas en sortir indemne j'ai là j'ai
pas de haine je n'ai pas de rancoeur il
ya des questions
ouais je construise un tas de questions
mais
soit qu'on puisse dire qu'on puisse
faire personne pour rendre ses 15 ans
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
patrick dils près de belfort à méziré où
il habite depuis sa libération il vit
avec son chat et depuis peu avec anaïs
sa fiancée maintenant de anan eh ben
j'ai rencontré
je dirais ma moitié celle qui me permet
d'avancer
celle qui me permet d'être serein de
croire en un avenir encore plus beau et
plus plus ensoleillés et surtout celle
qui a su me rendre mes 16 ans puisqu'il
est beau et fort avec ma fiancée anaïs
c'est qu'elle me suis pleinement dans
mes projets de l'association puisque
mais paul énormément et puis elle croit
vraiment en moi et puis même avec un
amour très fort et travaux en 2002 après
15 années de prison patrick dils est
innocenté aujourd'hui grâce à un nouvel
emploi il tente d'oublier sa
condamnation pour le meurtre de deux
enfants
là je suis à société comme magasinier
cariste
je m'occupe donc des réceptions et des
explosifs des expéditions pardon au
quotidien
il est ici incognito ou presque
[Musique]
on a juste fait une réunion préalable à
l'arrivée de patrick de manière à dire
voilà on a embauché quelqu'un c'est
quelqu'un que vous connaissez parce
qu'il est très médiatisée pour l'instant
par contre on l'accueille au sein de la
société comme un collègue lambda tout le
monde a parfaitement compris la
situation on a eu quelques questions et
puis à partir du moment où patrick est
arrivé toutes les choses sont devenues
absolument naturel pour tout le monde
à sa sortie de prison patrick dils a été
indemnisé à hauteur d'un million d'euros
si je me suis déjà entendu dire à
l'essor de la société comme dans la
société ou qu'est ce que je fais ici et
tout le moment j'ai pu gagner je suis
désolé
premièrement déjà cette somme tk qu'elle
soit ne regarde pas les autres
et puis surtout
le travail c'est vital c'est pour se
sentir exister c'est pour se sentir
utile
patrick a monté son association elle
offre une aide matérielle pour améliorer
la scolarité des enfants en difficulté
voire arlette c'est une amie de travail
qui s'est investi à fond dans
l'association
[Musique]
je sais pas la course à quoi mais c'est
la course alors quand je dis je viens
pour on essaie de faire le poids avec
arlette et sa trentaine d'adhérents
l'association dessine des cartes
postales confectionne des gâteaux et des
confitures qu'il vend dans la région
pour récolter des fond se contentant de
dire ouais elle tout premier layani
willy feraient bien d'en donner assure
l'association
et bien aujourd'hui encore je vous dis
non je vous dis non non pas parce que je
n'en ai pas envie
non pas parce que je ne peux pas mais
simplement je pense que le geste est
beaucoup plus beau de donner de son
temps et de son énergie pour une
association qu'une donner de l'argent et
patrick fait le tour des commerçants de
son village
alors là c'est la bouche je m'arrête
tous les matins pour prendre mon petit
déjeuner avec le patron je pense que
cette année ça lui posera pas de quoi
non plus pour représenter l'association
est à côté il ya la coiffeuse où je me
fais couper les cheveux de temps en
temps et qui avait déjà participé qu'à
que c'était l'année dernière de parler
nom de l'association
je pense que ça ne posera pas de
problème non plus cette année cela lui
permet par ailleurs de nouer des
contacts
on va passer à la maison radio wifi n va
est datée en face c'est très appréciable
c'est que maintenant les gens me
connaissent et c'est instinctif salut
patrick bonne journée
et eux
bon appétit
home encourageons bon week-end oublier
l'injustice et faire oublier qu'on a été
condamné à perpétuité
voilà le credo de patrick dils et
maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
patrick dils
bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue dans tout le
monde en a parlé
merci alors patrick vous êtes né le 30
juin 1970 à montigny les metz en moselle
ou votre famille habite rue venesi l'os
tout près du long talus qui borde la
voie ferrée de l'express paris met un
ouvrier spécialisé d'abord à la sollac
certaines sociétés qui fabriquent et
cuisine la ferraille en fait et ensuite
chez citroën celle ci travaille à votre
maman et testing dactylo jusqu'à votre
naissance ensuite laisser occuper de
vous et oui alors à l'école votre grande
taille votre grand mener votre allure
dégingandée et vos cheveux roux suscite
des moqueries même des insultes
tout à fait et de par ma timidité
le fait d'être introverti pas la
capacité de pouvoir répondre
effectivement j'en ai beaucoup souffert
alors vous renfermez sur vous même et
vous vous réfugiez dans votre collection
de timbres en fait votre rêve c'est de
devenir cuisinier d'ailleurs à 14 ans
vous arrêter l'école pour commencer une
formation de cap2 de cuisine alors à
l'époque des faits vous avez 16 ans mais
encore un peu un enfant on peut dire
vous n'êtes pas vous n'êtes pas demeurer
vous n'êtes pas débile mais vous êtes
vraiment retard quoi tout à fait plus
n'ayons pas peur des mots effectivement
un enfant un enfant alors le 28
septembre 1986 vers 18h45
rentrée avec votre papa votre maman et
votre frère de week-end dans la meuse
vous possédez une maison de campagne
pendant que vos parents et votre frère
décharge la voiture vous vous dirigez
vers la poubelle administrative de
lusine demathieu et bard où vous venez
chercher des timbres pour votre élection
effectivement j'avais pour habitude de
me rendre à cette petite poubelle où il
y avait que des déchets administratif
pour essayer d'assouvir ma passion pour
la philatélie est de récolter quelques
timbres vous en trouviez de temps en
temps par à chaque cours est ce fameux
soir j'étais revenue bredouille
le soir même à 19h30 les corps de deux
enfants sont retrouvé couché sur les
rails du talus à quelques centaines de
mètres de chez vous il s'agit de cyril
beining et alexandre beckrich 8 ans tous
les deux qui aimait bien faire du vélo
rue venizelos
vous le connaissiez gens connaissaient
un des deux ti alexandre s'il habite à
quelques maisons deux de celle de mes
parents
par contre son petit copain et je ne
connaissais pas peut-être croisé comme
ça de vue dans le quartier mais
sont vraiment sans plus alors venez
jouer sur les voies désaffectées ou
stationner les wagons de marchandises
oui apparemment j'ai su par la suite que
c'était un air de jeu pour privilégier
pour les enfants alors quand on trouve
le les corps des deux garçonnets
la scène est insoutenable ils ont le
crâne explosé à coups de pierres des
fragments osseux des morceaux de
matières cervicales ont été projetés
dans un rayon de 2 2 m lorsque l'
enquête de voisinage commencent les
policiers notent rien à signaler chez
les deals tout à fait mais le lendemain
il ya un coup de fil anonyme et vous
êtes mis en garde à vue interrogée sur
mon emploi du temps
et puis je vais finir par dire que je me
rends compte que j'étais dans leur
église et l'os est ma raison dans cette
rue pour chercher les timbres alors vous
êtes interrogés mais sans résultat parce
qu'en fait les enfants ont été tués
entre 17 et 18 heures et vous vous êtes
revenu avec vos parents de votre maison
de campagne dans la meuse autour de
18h45 le maire d'izon ait lieu au moins
trois quarts d'heure avant le retour de
la famille dils mais quelques mois plus
tard à un nouveau témoignage va tout
changer
ça fait il ya un nouveau témoignage qui
tombait qui dit avoir entendu des pleurs
d'enfant aux alentours de 18h45 ont
effectivement pour la police ça change
la donne il a effectivement à ce moment
là j'étais dans la rue ou gazmont là
vous pouvez être le meurtrier
alors après 30 heures d'interrogatoire
vous finissez par par avouer
pourquoi pourquoi à la lassitude je sais
pas si vous avez déjà arrivé là
maintenant tout de suite à imaginer ce
que ça peut représenter 30
c'est pas trop longtemps dans votre
salon s'est pas trompé en très bonne
compagnie c'est la police judiciaire qui
sont là pour recueillir des aveux pour
pouvoir obtenir le résultat est encore
une fois 16 ans je n'étais qu'un enfant
donc
oui effectivement j'ai endossé l'habit
du parfait coupable mais je pense qu'il
serait quand même bon de dire qu'avant
moi deux majeurs ont été amenés avoué le
meurtre dans les détails comme moi j'ai
été amené à le faire donc si des
majeures peuvent le faire un enfant mais
c'est maniable sa mort fait pâte à
modeler 30 heures sans dormir 31
s'endormir sans manger c
et c'est à ce tableau je pense qu'il ya
pas de mots pour expliquer les
conditions canton je m'entends dire même
encore au jour d'aujourd'hui si on vient
en parler oui mais il ya eu des temps de
repos a remis à temps de repos c'est
quoi un temps de repos
c'est une mise en condition pour obtenir
du résultat parce qu'on vous pose un tas
de questions et à la sortie du repos on
veut les réponses
donc c'est pas un temps de repos
n'hésitez combien les flics trois ou
quatre a quand même et se relayer en
fait donc à ce moment là vous vous
pensez que les policiers vont se rendre
compte que vous avez menti
en fait vous rentrerez chez vous 15 ans
plus tard vous êtes venir le plus jeune
condamné à perpétuité de france c'est à
dire que le fait que vous soyez mineur
n'a pas joué pour vous s'allumant pas
c'est la ricine ça quand même c'est
unique
ouais c'est tout simplement lamentable
passé c'est une cas pas de me coincer
ces on a détruit mon adolescence on a
détruit une partie de moi est une partie
de ma famille vous ne seriez me sentais
qu en 2002 en fait tout ça parce que
vous ne vouliez pas avoué aux policiers
que vous alliez chercher des timbres
c'est vrai dans la poubelle sa part de
ce bien ce petit mensonge si j'estime
même pas un mensonge c'est nos missions
de dire la vérité pourquoi parce que en
sachant tout ce que j'avais vécu par
rapport à l'école les moqueries et
railleries même si aujourd'hui je me
rends compte que c'est c'est stupide
ça n'a même pas lieu d'être mais
l'enfant il n'aurait pas supporté en
plus ce qu'on dit mais elle et abuse et
de petits deals cela c'est un fouillis
poubelle ça aurait été la goutte d'eau
qui a fait déborder le vase
tout ça par peur du qu'en dira-t-on dû
fournir à tort alors le crime n'a jamais
été élucidé
à un moment on a mis ça sur le dos de
francis heaulme
mais le
les tests adn ont prouvé que ce n'était
pas possible que ça soit lui le dossier
est toujours ouvert et j'espère très
sincèrement avant tout pour les familles
de victimes pour ma propre famille et
puis moi même et mon entourage qu'un
jour on se voit ce qui s'est passé sur
ce talus et pourquoi on a enlevé la vie
à ses deux enfants qui comme moi ne
demander qu'une seule chose vivre
grandir et être heureux en prison
c'était très difficile pour vous non
vous avez retrouvé les les railleries
les insultes de l'école pire que ça
parce que en prison il ya une hiérarchie
sociale
malheureusement il ya les délits qu'ils
font est respectée comme le braquage et
autres et puis après on va descendre des
sans descendre jusqu'au moment on va
arriver aux nôtres de personnes âgées
mais après les passages il ya encore
pire ces meurtres d'enfants
c'est vraiment c'est les gens qu'on ne
peut pas respecter ce sont des gens qui
sont là pour subir pour souffrir et qui
ne doivent pas exister
non je suis malheureusement passé par
toutes les étapes
ça va commencer par des insultes des
regards les violences physiques le
racket et puis bien évidemment le violet
quoi vous dites on a volé 15 ans de ma
vie c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
rattrape pas alors il faut essayer de
vivre avec l'état à verser 1 million
d'euros que vous m'avez fait de ce
million d'euros sept cent mille euros -
étaient destinées quarante mille euros
ont été décidés à mon frère alain et
80000 euros pour chacun de mes parents
ce qui fait un total de 900 mille euros
étaient les 100 millions restants
destiné à mon ami avocat mais ce que
vous avez vécu ça se chiffre pas
j'imagine mais savez on peut on peut
chiffrer 15 ans de galère par rapport à
un manque à gagner au niveau d'un
salaire mais si vous pensez sincèrement
qu'on peut chiffrer un préjudice moral
la très jolie ce physique
ça se chiffre pas et si on avait eu la
décence de me demander ce que j'aurais
souhaité en réparation croyez moi sur
parole
j'aurais jamais demandé
en team à l'état mais est ce que j'aurai
tout simplement souhaiter que les gens
qui on va faire un mois de près ou de
loin
vive et subissent ce que j'ai vécu et
subi durant ces quinze années et là on
aura été quitte
vous en voulez à qui aujourd'hui j'en
veux à personne
aujourd'hui j'ai pas de temps à perdre
j'ai put un terrain et la vengeance la
haine
elle sert à rien s'il permettait de
faire revenir la jeunesse à mes parents
ça pouvait ramener la vie à ses enfants
oui j'en aurai mais là il ne sert à rien
et j'essaie tout simplement d'avancer
sereinement dans la ville alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes magasinier cariste
dans une fabrique d'articles culinaires
vous avez trouvé l'amour un jeune
français de 18 ans qui est charmante
effectivement comme n'importe qui j'ai
pu avoir différentes petites histoires
parce que je suis loin d'être un don
juan je suis juste patrick mais je pense
que c'est la seule qui a su me
comprendre qu'ils assument aimé qu'à
suez mais patrick et non pas dils même
si on peut pas dissocier 10 de patrick
puisque la fais partie l'autre mais qui
m'aime pour ce que je suis et non pas
parce que je représente
quand vous êtes tous les deux vous
parlez des fois de la faire bien sûr ça
fait partie de ma vie ça fait partie de
notre vie aujourd'hui mais ça prend
jamais le dessus
on a notre vie à construire on a nos
projets ensemble est en avance
sereinement
vous dites je suis l'homme le plus
heureux de la terre aujourd'hui
effectivement je suis l'homme le plus
sur la table parce que je suis plus tout
seul je suis j'ai une compagne j'ai une
fiancée parce que c'est le vrai mot qui
m'aiment
vraiment et qui est prête à faire
n'importe quoi pour moi comme moi
personnellement je suis prêt à faire
n'importe quoi pour elle alors si
c'était à refaire patrick qu'est-ce que
vous ne referiez pas pareil c'est très
délicat vous répondre je sais pas je
pense que je resterai le patrick que
vous avez devant vous aujourd'hui le
jour j'allais mourir voudriez qu'on
marque quoi sur votre tombe vous savez
qu'à les questions mais j'ai pas envie
de mourir je suis pas envie de mourir
parce que je pense qu'après tout ce qui
m'est arrivé
ben j'ai beaucoup de choses à faire
comme je le disais tout à l'heure je
n'ai pas de haine et j'ai envie de
tendre une main vers les autres ceux qui
en ont besoin
vous pourrez remarquer patrick dils il
est mort sans haine pourquoi pas moi on
voit patrick j'étais très heureux de
rallumer la lumière sur vous merci merci
à vous enfin les pointures de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu